[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour vous faire vivre
les travaux des sénateurs le sénat
poursuit sa commission d' enquête sur
l'incendié de l'usiné lubrizol à rouen
trois mois après le drame
lusine lubrizol va pouvoir relancer son
activité partiellement les sénateurs
s'intéresse aujourd'hui à l'autre usine
qui a brûlé dans cet incendie
l'entrepôt normandie logistique qui
stockaient des produits lubrizol mais
n'était pas classé à risques le sénat
auditionne les dirigeants de normandie
logistique je vous laisse écouter cette
audition le propos liminaire en fait on
a préparé un petit powerpoint déjà
c'était pour resituer les entreprises
dans dans le contexte
en fait nous sommes à un groupe de
logistique
une petite entreprise finalement au
regard de comparer avec une auréole mais
nous sommes une entreprise multisite que
nous sommes à la fois sur la région
rouennaise caennaise le havre rennes et
angers nous faisons trois métiers
différents
donc le premier c'est le transport qui
représente 80 % de notre activité
le deuxième c'est donc l'entreposage et
le troisième c'est le les prestations de
transitaire l'activité qui a été
impactée par le sinistre concerne une
une de nos structures qui s'appelle enel
logistique et qui est une petite
structure de 50 personnes avec on va
dire six sites logistiques dont 3 euros
en 1 sur le havre et un sur caen donc
l'entreprise dans sa globalité
donc le groupe nomade et logistiques
donc représente 500 salariés
le site qui était impacté uniquement
environ entre quatre et cinq salariés
donc faut comprendre que la taille
quelque part et les prestations en fait
été réalisé dans ce site était
simplement des prestations de
de justic de base d'entrée sortie de
stock de stockage pour différents
clients
donc on a rappelé en fait les secteurs
d'activité sur lequel on est on est
actif mais principalement on est on est
plutôt sur l'agroalimentaire et la
partie chimie en fait qui concerne le
réseau on peut quasiment dire que
lubrizol était notre seul client en fait
sur deux par sa proximité et qu'on est
bon on n'est pas des spécialistes de la
chimie du tout en fait c'est pas une
spécialité girex et l'opportunité en
fait d'un un client de proximité qui a
fait qu'on a travaillé avec coco est
historiquement je moi je connais pas
l'historique mais moi j'ai repris
l'entreprise en en 2011 et les relations
commerciales existait depuis très
longtemps avec cette entreprise
donc concernant gérer notre notre
situation faite par rapport au sinistre
qui était enfin le sinistre les locaux
sinistrés le
on l'appelle ce site d' enquête france
puisqu'il est en bordure de seine et
ceux cités est mitoyen c'est intéressant
de remontrer en fait la photo du site
est mitoyen sur 300 m avec une résolve
donc c'est un site extrêmement
particulier puisque comme vous le voyez
sur le sur le sur la photo vous avez
donc à gauche le site lubrizol à droite
en bas c'est rien dit ce qui est une
installation classée aussi seveso et la
banque de terrains que nous occupions
au plus court ses 30 mètres de large
autant vous dire que si aujourd'hui on
avait à reconstruire un site de stockage
sur un telle ou telle bande de terrain
ce serait totalement impossible d'autant
plus qu'il faut en principe 20 mètres de
chaque côté d'un bâtiment donc trois
mètres de large dans vous dire que alors
pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est juste pour
que vous compreniez que en fait ce site
c'est un site qui date des années 20 et
donc les industriels qui nous entoure
il ya une photo également qui montre le
site ont soixante dix huit donc il n'est
pas très fin c'est pas très très vieux
mais il y a
lubrizol n'existait pas en tant que tel
il du stockage de bois de chaque côté
c'est des activités qui se sont collés
en fait à nos entrepôts et c'est pour ça
que nous bénéficions du rappel
l'antériorité donc je voudrais rappeler
également que dans le cadre du pprt
il ya un slide aussi que vous n'êtes pas
ces agressions qui donne un petit peu
alors juste pour votre compréhension
donc le situe bridole nous notre notre
installation c'est sûr petit et r2 je
sais pas si vous voyez sur l'écran la
zone rouge
quadrillés ce que je veux juste rappeler
c'est que le l'impact sur nos entre
notre entreprise
quelque part du hac était prévu en fait
dans le cadre de l'étude de berthet
correspond en fait à la destruction qui
ait lieu sur nos bâtiments
il ya une photo juste après fin que
pourrait passer aussi qui donne en fait
l'ensemble des bâtiments qui ont été
impactée par l'incendié
donc c'est parti donc t3 t4 t2b t2c t1b
est en fait sur le plan pprt la zone
impactée c'est exactement en fait ce qui
était prévu donc
j'irai nous ne sommes pas nous avons pas
été du tout acteur dans pprt
nous avons été juste consulter à ne pas
consulter nous avons eu un retour à
rendez-vous avec l'administration que
d'une voix qui nous a dit oui bah c'est
vrai vous auriez peut-être dû être
délaissés
mais l'état n'a pas d'argent donc bain
continuez comme ça quoi on se demandera
donc vous pouvez préciser ce que
signifie vous auriez dû être délaissés
j'ai acquis des dispositions qui font
que lorsque vous êtes dans une rod une
zone
alors c'est une zone rouge dit
interdiction vous l'état peut c'est pas
obligé mais peu jeu nous exproprier en
fait donc c'était ça aurait pu être le
cas et quand on a pris connaissance en
fait de ce pprt
il y avait auparavant déjà des
discussions avec l'ue résolve pour une
acquisition du site et donc c'est vrai
que nous est apparu que compte-tenu
effectivement de la zone de danger que
c'était plus sage que lubrizol en fait
avec acquiert ce site et discussion donc
ont eu lieu pendant un certain nombre
d'années ils ont failli en fait aboutir
en 2017 et un 2017 pour des raisons
financières
alors que tout était prêt à de notre
côté pour déménager en fait l activité
qu'on avait sur ce site
lubrizol cédé 10 ans à cause de
problèmes financiers aux us et à cette
époque donc en 2017 la dréal donc avait
visité notre site
j'irai de fond en comble il ya eu un
salon des études de sol en fin de 2
mais et de pur pour que les
prescriptions nécessaire pour que ce
site soit intégrée dans le site seveso
soit réalisée et ça faisait partie
quelque part de d'une condition en fait
que lubrizol nous donner pour faire
l'acquisition du site où il savoir le
coup que que qui seraient impactés
puisque lorsqu'un site de d'autre nature
est intégré à gérer une installations
seveso
il faut que les prescriptions des dix
ans est nécessaire dans le cadre seveso
soit soit applicable en fait à
l'ensemble du site dont le site qui
serait intégré moi je veux juste
rappeler le sait une chose qui a un
salaire de 2 d'éléments qui ont été qui
ont été donnés giresse sur nos nous
notre installation
il faut savoir que nous nous stoppions
en fait sur ces bâtiments uniquement des
produits combustibles qui répondent en
fait à une nomenclature icpe ce que
c'est la rubrique 15 10 et un produit
comme stx est pas un produit inflammable
et nous stoppions pas de produits
toxiques dangereux en fait c'étaient les
produits de nature très différente de ce
que
comment dire que lubrizol stocker en
fait dans ces bâtiments
d'ailleurs ça a été confirmée par le pdg
de lubrizol s'était confirmée par le
réal en fait ce sont pas les mêmes
produits et donc nous ne sommes pas un
site seveso et surtout pas un site
seveso seuil haut
nous sommes une installation j'irai de
stockage où on stocke des produits
certes qui sont utilisés par lubrizol ou
qu'ils proviennent de lubrizol
mais ce sont des produits qui ne sont
pas de même nature et de même qu'ils
sont les produits dont combustible
et qui n'ont qui n'ont pas su les deux
qui nous a une qui nécessitent pas des
caractéristiques de prescriptions
spécifiques pour se protéger contre des
dangers qu'ils ne sont pas inhérents à
ce type de produits c'est vraiment de à
part le rapporteur je vais évoquer le
point le premier on a souvent entendu
dire notamment parlé par les médias que
vous auriez l'ua a stockées des matières
que lubrizol ne voulait pas garder sur
son site et que d'une certaine manière
ça aurait été pour eux ce qui explique
peut-être d'ailleurs que l'acquisition
du terrain ne se soit pas fait la
possibilité pour eux d'avoir un dans
leur périmètre
une certaine manière une partie des
installations qui ne soit pas classé
seveso alors prenez la première chose
l'acquisition en fête devait se faire en
octobre 2020 devait on devait reprendre
les discussions en octobre 2019 donc
toute façon il était toujours intéressé
il souhaitait faire la faire
l'acquisition est bon là beaucoup des
changes avec eux fait qu'il qui le
prouver je dirais qu'on veut pas peut
pas dire qu'il voulait pas le faire il
voulait le faire sauf que ça n'a pas
abouti mais c'est de leur faites surtout
pas d'une autre en fait on avait négocié
la chose le prix depuis longtemps
concernant votre deuxième question
en fait nous
notre métier c'est de stocker en fait
des produits que nous nous proposent nos
clients et qui correspondent aux
caractéristiques que l'on peut stocker
ce qui se passe du coup de lubrizol nous
c'est bien qu'on soit voisin d'un site
seveso et c'est peut-être peut-être un
problème de législation actuelle mais on
n'a jamais été concerné par gérer aucune
on n'a aucun lien avec eux sur ce genre
de sujet et donc nous ont stocké des
produits certes qui correspondait à
notre classification mais le lien avec
l'ordre problématiques de stockage chez
eux de cesser totalement étranger quoi
donc je peux pas vraiment répondre à
votre question en disant des mais
pourquoi est-ce que je brise hall où les
stocker chez nous je suis je suppose
simplement qu'il n'y a pas la place de
ce que chez eux après leur autorisation
en rond on la connaît pas en fait on ne
peut pas imaginer que c'était plus
simple moins contrôlés de ce qu'est chez
vous que chez eux
non puisque en fait c'est pas un
problème de contrôle puisque les
produits que nous ont stocké pour eux
étaient des produits qu'on pourrait
stocker la question à quel jeu je pense
je peux pas répondre c est ce que si les
produits avaient été chez eux
est-ce qu'ils auraient été soumis à
quelque chose auquel nous n'aurait pas
été soumis ça j'en sais rien mais ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que revient le les
produits combustibles
c'est en fait c'est pour lui de base
dans les deux manches la thur icpe
on va dire cette premier niveau c'est un
produit banal mais qui n'a pas de
caractère des caractéristiques
spécifiques qui lie ces produits-là à
une activité dangereuse chimiques
toxiques seveso ça donc pourquoi est ce
que chez nous je pense simplement pour
des questions de coûts pour des
questions de coûts parce que la
proximité du site faisait que les coûts
logistiques de transfert en fait
d'inciter à noter été réduit et essai je
pense que c'est la seule raison
autrement il aurait stocké voilà
ailleurs et nous ce qu'on a constaté
mais plutôt à postériori qu'a priori
c'est que la zone peut être chrétien
peut revenir sur le la zone ceux du
départ peut-être là juste à celle
d'avant la zone où enfin le départ de
feu a priori a eu lieu
c'est cette zone si vous voulez qui use
the past oui le stockage extérieur sur
le bâtiment
c'est dans cette zone et c'est une photo
qui est quand même assez ancienne 2012
et c'est vrai que des relents de
stockage extérieur et donc on peut
supposer c'est ce qu'on suppose aussi
c'est que ces stockages était peut-être
déborder un peu mais ça c'est mais c'est
leur problème à eux c'est pas notre
problème nous on a on se considère comme
une victime souhaite cet incendie on l'a
on l'a répété plusieurs fois mais gérer
que pour nous il est impossible que
l'instant ne sont pas dites chez nous on
nous assure heurts ont fait des enquêtes
et on fait intervenir donc laboratoires
spécialisés en en 410 blessés ils sont
ils sont formels sur le fait que ça peut
pas venir de chez nous donc on n'a pas
géré nous on se considère plus comme une
victime plutôt que comme étant on est un
acteur certes parce qu'on est classée
donc on a il cpe et donc on bon bah on
participe à toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour mais voilà même bonne
foi est ce que justement parce que vous
stockez des produits combustibles c'est
justement pour cette raison que le feu
ne peut pas être partie 2
l'océan parti s'est pas uniquement c'est
une raison qui est bien sûr c'est que en
fait après du combustible
c'est une question de point éclair sert
pour faire démarrer à feu plus le point
éclair est bas plus les incendies peut
développer rapidement et est chez nous
en fait c'est comme ça d'un feu dans un
cheminot mettez des bûches avant que ça
démarre ce samedi un certain temps quoi
donc il faut nous ramassons dit en fait
l'ensemble des demandes détection que
l'on avait et la nature des pour les
cons stocker effectivement c'est nous on
parle en dormant dans la conviction et
l'expert d'assurance qui a fait son
travail nous a dit la même chose il ne
veut pas partir chez vous c'est papa
c'est quoi pouvait continuer même à
porter sur d'autres questions
oui j'avais une question sur la sous
traitance président l'a évoqué dans son
new d'introduction
nous réfléchissons sur sa déjà été
évoqué à plusieurs reprises l'idée de
d'interdire la sous traitance ou de
l'encadrer enfin en tout cas il est
montré que les sous traitants n'ont pas
nécessairement le degré de formation dsr
sur des sites qui sont classés a
fortiori seveso donc est-ce que quelle
approche vous avez ce que vous même afin
que vous avez dit vous êtes une petite
structure quatre ou cinq salariés sa
danse danse danse est cet entrepôt donc
j'imagine que vous ne vous faites pas
intervenir des sous traitants dans cet
entrepôt la barre ou simplement pour la
maintenance par exemple si ça peut être
juste pas par exemple pour la
maintenance des équipements de sécurité
et donc vous assurer de leur formation
j'imagine avec l approche vous avez en
matière de sous-traitance sur des sites
classés et a fortiori sur les excès
réseau alors je serai revenir sur notre
informatique du classement en fait si je
veux résumé en fait le classement icpe
il en fait il ya deux critères
principaux c'est la nature des produits
que l'on stocke et la taille des
bâtiments mon stock
nous nous étions en fait dans ce qu'on
appelle le deuxième 2ème niveau
c'est-à-dire est là derrière il n'y a
pas de classement du tout ça
on tienne là la déclaration et la
déclaration c'est à partir de 500 tonnes
de produits stockés donc ça 100 tonnes
c'est très très petit bâtiment de 500 m²
donc c'est ensuite il ya le au dessus de
500 tonnes vous êtes en régime de
déclaration
nous nos entrepôts faisait plus de
cinquante mille mètres cubes ce qui est
un autre seuil c'est à dire que le
premier seuil c'est un seuil de poids
les solutions avancées les seuils de
volume volume des bâtiments de stockage
pour une adresse salaires pour
l'ensemble du site et en était
légèrement supérieur à 50 mille mètres
carrés donc on était dans ce qu'on
appelle un régime d'enregistrement mais
avec un régime d'intériorité
et donc c'est une polémique aussi car
enlever la dréal à ce sujet qu on réfute
mai mais je dirais que c'est ça un sujet
un entier le troisième niveau c'est
l'autorisation ces bâtiments qui font
plus de 300 millimètres cube qui sont
encore plus importants et après on
arrive sur des bâtiments donc
seveso et après seveso seuil haut donc
nous on était sur le deuxième niveau qui
est un niveau d'enregistrement après il
ya la nature des produits que l'on
stocke donc la nature des produits
le premier niveau c'est la 15 10 à gré à
la rubrique 15 10 alors ça veut dire en
fait comment dire marchandise générale
c'est à dire ces cristaux qu'est ce que
vous voulez mais c'est l'exclusion de
certains types de produits spécifiques
que que la législation donc à hanga dhr
ça peut être des produits par exemple au
plastique où il faut cédric particulière
ou des produits inflammables et à toutes
sortes de produits
et quand on est en 15 10 est recommandée
sur le seuil quasiment fatale à la
rubrique la plus basse de type de
produits donc ce que l'on stocké en fait
dans ces bâtiments c'est que je veux
insister là dessus c'est que ce sont des
produits de base c'est pas des produits
s'ils voulaient qu'ils sont par nature
qu une dangerosité qui mériterait des
prescriptions
j'irai extraordinaire spécifique est ce
qui caractérise un petit peu notre
installation c'est que du fait de cette
antériorité c'est à dire du fait que ses
entrepôts étaient très ancien est
imbriqué dans une
une zone bien que j'ai rappelé le pprt
nous mettez dans une zone de danger
nous étions si vous voulez sur un niveau
de prescription relativement bas par
rapport à nos une entreprise qui aurait
stocké d'autres types de produits
vous avez pas la sous traitance nous en
fait on n'est pas un sous traitant
c'est ça qu'on veut aussi vous expliquer
c'est que nous sommes à prestataires de
services indépendants multi clients
c'est à dire que ont stocké dans ces
bâtiments là des produits certes pour
lubrizol en quantités significatives une
sanction si les produits d'autres
clients entre autres on avait de la
gomme arabique en quantité relativement
importante on avait à peu près de 1000
tonnes de communes de gomme arabique ont
cité c'était pour un pour un autre
client de la bauxite de gens remaniées
zig et des produits qui sont si vous
voulez qu'ils correspondent à la
classification mais qui sont pas des
produits en lien avec l'uimm raisonne en
termes de sous traitance la sous
traitance que nous faisons intervenir
dans notre site c'était extrêmement
ponctuels mais c'est une sous traitance
on va dire où il n'ya pas de
prescriptions particulières année de
formation particulière à donner à
quelqu'un qui vient dont par exemple
c'est le métier de donner des permis de
feu par exemple si quelqu'un venait et
avait à faire intervenir les utiliser je
dois voir un point chaud donc c'est la
réglementation mais j'aimerais que on
est un espace sûr n'est pas soumis en
fait dans ce type d'installation à une
sous traitance active sur lequel on
aurait à faire des formations
spécifiques le note personnelle était
formée pour pour
mais le type de produit en fait que l'on
stocké mai mais les prestataires qui
pouvait intervenir mais façon assez
extrêmement vins rares nouveautés on
entend une fois par mois deux fois par
mois j'en sais rien mais très très peu
on n'avait pas la sphère formation
spécifique hormis les permis de feu
alors ce sont par rapport au sinistre
les bâtiments par rapport à l'or de
l'extension du sinistre est à peu près
entre 9 et 10 heures entre le enfin le
départ de la 1ère personne des entrepôts
et lors du sinistre dont on avait
personne sur le site depuis environ deux
heures c'est un site qui était donc avec
un système de surveillance le relier à
un pc donc un prestataire agréé apsad
qui on avait donc d un système
anti-intrusion de détection d'intrusion
dans notre peau et un système de
détection incendie est donc tout report
d'alarm été reporté à ce pc qui lui-même
reporté aussi a dit qu'une intervention
cours est donc tout à l'heure je parlais
de d2 de déclenchement en fait d alarme
qu'on a eu qu'une qui nous qui nous
conforte dans la le scénario du départ
du feu à l'extérieur de chez nous le pc
en question a eu effectivement des des
reports des larmes et on sait exactement
en fait dire sur les bâtiments
à quel moment le fumée s'est déclenché à
quel moment
c'est devenu un incendie sur les
différents bâtiments qui ont été
impactés jusqu'à que ça devienne un
brasier relativement important est ce
que ce qu'on a vu nous c'est que parce
qu'on a découvert évidemment après mais
c'est que c'est un incendie qui a été
extrêmement rapide était très violent
sur le ronde a visionné un film d'une
nacelle ou qu'étant qui dans l'axé des
bâtiments et on était surpris nous mêmes
de la vitesse à laquelle elle a 110 cdc
dégagée ponctuellement compléter votre
question pour la sous-traitance
[Musique]
souvent la sous traitance elle se
comprend quand des sociétés extérieures
interviennent sur le site du donneur
d'ordre
donc là on était sur un site qui était
le nôtre et sur les marchandises qui
nous sont confiés que ce soit par
lubrizol pour d'autres clients
on ne fait aucune intervention sur les
matières dire que quand on rentre une
palette sur lesquels il ya quatre fûts
aux touches à rien on des
conditionnements reconditionne pas on
fait pas de mélange
c'est vraiment des opérations très
basique de déchargement de palettes qui
sont sur un camion comprend un cas
chariots élévateurs donc avec du
personnel qui formé pour la manutention
et la mise en dépôt
ça se limite que cas cela donc aucune
intervention technique mécanique
au contraire de certains industriels qui
effectivement font appel à des sociétés
extérieur mais sur leur site pour faire
des opérations donc là nous c'est
vraiment de l'opération 2
enfin manutention mise en entrepôt
reprises le cas échéant et rechargement
donc c'est vraiment avec nous avait avec
nos personnels surtout chasser ces
c'est parfois là parce que le rhône
canton et fournisseurs on est toujours
sous traitants d'anor dorner mais si
j'ai bien compris par rapport à votre
réflexion
on est on y passe intervenant sur la
chaîne de production
voilà merci eux-mêmes
merci monsieur le président moi je vais
d'abord posé une question au nom de ma
collègue christine bonfanti qui tu es
obligé de partir qui rapportera donc
l'administration bien qu'exerçant selon
elle une surveillance très étroite du
site lubrizol a déclaré pendant
plusieurs jours ne pas connaître les
produits stockés dans cet établissement
comme dans les entrepôts mitoyen de
normandie logistiques donc vous
entrepôts cela atteste de
dysfonctionnements violation de la
directive seveso 3 du casier 2012
relatives aux accidents majeurs
impliquant des substances dangereuses
ainsi selon les dispositions de
l'article 7 l'exploitant doit
communiquer à l'autorité compétente
les informations qui permettent
d'identifier les substances dangereuses
leur quantité
leur forme physique tout comme
l'activité exercée ou prévus dans la
zone de stockage d'évident cela n'a pas
été le cas
alors pourquoi alors que la loi vous y
oblige et n'avez vous pas indiqué
clairement l'administration notamment
les quantités qui ont été stockés
maintenant moi j'ai d'autres questions
la première il me semble que dans les
entreprises de transport et logistique
quand il ya des matières dites
dangereuses il ya un référent matières
dangereuses cmr donc est-ce que vous
avez une personne identifiée et proches
notamment de votre de votre site et
ensuite mon j'ai bien entendu sur sur la
larme
maintenant cette cet accident est-ce que
vous ça vous amène à apporter des
modifications dans vos process dans
votre document d'évaluation des risques
enfin pour vous préserver ce que suite à
ça vous allez pas liées justement des
dysfonctionnements éventuels
merci même rooney se schmidt
oui j'aurais juste revenir sur le début
de votre question vous parlez de
produits dangereux et d'obligations à
site seveso
le problème c'est que nous sommes pas un
site seveso et nous stockons pâte
produits dangereux et unis de produits
inflammables donc en fait c'est la
polémique sur laquelle on tourne depuis
géré le début de cette crise nous ne
sommes pas du tout un site on va dire de
type seveso et encore moins nous
stockons pas de produits inflammables
les produits dangereux donc les
obligations qui incombent à ce type
d'établissement
certes on peut peut-être regretter que
les voisins immédiats soient pas obligés
de faire la même chose enfin de passe
que par effet domino pas réparé fait des
mille dominos quelque part on voit bien
que l'impact et c'était prévu un pprt
je comprends tout à fait en fait votre
question mais mais quelque part c'est
pour nous c'était pas une obligation
donc sur sur ce plan voilà de stocker
concernant le transport effectivement
est ce qu'on appelle la dr nous dans
l'entreprise de transports que nous que
l'exploitant en fait nous nous faisons
extrêmement peu d'air en faisant un peu
de conditionner parfois à l'eau enfin ou
deux en a des airs donc on attend on a
on a un référent effectivement la
sécurité et on a des des prescriptions
spécifiques quand on transporte en fait
des produits qui peuvent être dangereux
ça peut ça peut arriver dans les
quantités relativement réduite mais sur
des classes de la dr jerry relativement
basse dire qu'on n'est pas bons on a pas
de citer harnes et s'est informé on est
plutôt sur des dû conditionner palette
donc c'est ça peut être des pilotis look
concernant votre
troisième question concernant ce qu'on
peut tirer de cette crise et est ce
qu'on peut en tirer des enseignements en
fait sur parce qu'en fait on a comme je
vous le disais en fait six sites
logistiques différents dire que
malheureusement et c'était le seul site
qui était de cette nature c'est à dire
que l'ensemble de nos autres sites sont
des sites qui sont sous d'autorisation
d'ailleurs qui sont très différents
c'est à dire qu'ils ont dès qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus récent mais sur lesquels
nous avons des rubriques aussi de même
marchandise générale qui sont une
marchandise aussi des rubriques 15 10 et
j'irai que quand on a je pense vu qu'une
telle crise le recul nous fait penser
que on n'était peut-être pas très
préparée en fait à ce genre de crise
c'est depuis on va dire le mois de
septembre
ça commence à peu se calmer mais on a
vécu une période quand même très
difficile et on n'était pas très
préparée ça c'est clair
à la fois en termes de communication en
termes de d'equipe on s'est aperçu que
la nature du sinistre a son importance
nous a totalement submergé
est ce que si on a été préparée est ce
qu'on aurait pu faire mieux jusqu'à dire
j'en sais rien mais c'est c'est sûr que
on se doit peut-être de travailler plus
sûres
ils ont préparé vente seulement des
équipes qui soit disponible un peu plus
en terme de communication on a été un
peu défaillants parce que on est tous de
l'entreprise discrète et c'est vrai que
dans une crise comme ça les process il
faut s'entourer de personnes compétentes
et on s'est fait un peu on va dire
maltraité et j'irai qu on a considéré
avec le recul j'ai plusieurs amis qui me
l'an dont un psychologue qui m'a dit
mais c'est clair vous avez été un bouc
émissaire parfait pour cette crise est
malheureusement bassesse et on le subit
je suis vous avez à plusieurs reprises
dit que vous étiez victime que vous êtes
bouc émissaire n'est pas de l'avis sur
le sujet mais simplement et c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure en
commençant mon propos dans l'arrêté du 8
novembre il ya quand même un certain
nombre de manquements qui sont relevés
par par la dréal donc peut-être ville si
vous êtes peut-être bouc émissaire mais
vous avez quand même semble-t-il si j'en
crois
l'arrêté de la dréal commis quelques
manquements ou reprendre un terme assez
assez neutre on et réfute on a ciblé la
donc les manquements souligné par la
dréal vous les réfuter on a répondu à la
dréal en fait il y avait ce qu'on
appelle syseca réglementaire ils sont
pas réduites alors ne voit pas dans
l'udc 6 et il avait un septième qui
était finalement la conséquence d'une
des six donc pour chaque en fait
en fait la preuve le process habituel et
on a été très étonné d'ailleurs de la
latitude de la dréal l'autre en
commenter les déclarations de monsieur
monsieur berg qui ne va pour nous on a
considéré qu'il protégeait son
administration avant tout et et qu'il a
participé aussi à cette gérer ambiance
un peu délétère notre encontre de nous
faire aussi passer un peu pour gérer le
vilain canard
alors que nous gérer quelque part les
les écarts réglementaires qui ont été
gérés qui nous ont été notifiés on n'y a
répondu par écrit ban real pour nous
toute façon c'est même si quelques
écarts pouvaient peut-être nous est
opposé
il ya aucun lien de cause ou
d'aggravation du sinistre donc cette
polémique pour nous si vous voulez un
peu sans objet parce que il faut savoir
que on a
un peu d'expérience quand même dans les
relations avec l'inde rêve lorsque vous
avez un site d'installation classée vous
vous êtes comment dire pouvaient être
contrôlés et quand il ya un contrôle
l'administration en fait vous fait ces
remarques
il peut y avoir des des éléments
effectivement qui qui colle pas ou
géologie vous donner un exemple par
exemple d'inde et des manquements qui
nous est reproché notre système en fait
de détection incendie
la législation nous oblige en fait à
avoir un maintenance régulière de ses
installations
malheureusement pour nous donc quelque
part c'est un manquement vont l'amener à
issa il ya eu donc la chose suivante
c'est à dire qu'on a un look harris qui
a enfoncé une porte et qui a qui a fait
que le la société de maintenance qui
devait intervenir s'est présentée et
compte tenu que la porte était enfoncée
ils n'ont pas pu faire leur leur
maintenance à la date prévue
donc c'est une maintenance tous les ans
donc c'est est décalée au mois d'octobre
parce que pour réparer la porte pour
pour faire les détections sélection qui
sont élus m de haut il fallait une
nacelle et la nasa ne pouvait pas
rentrer dans le bâtiment donc exactement
c'est un manquement mais je dirais que
c'est un manquement gérer akli qui enfin
bon ok c'est un moment clé d'accord mais
mais mais mais quelque part s'il voulait
sais c'est pas c'est pas un manquement
grave c'est pas quelque chose les la
détection puis ça fonctionnait plus et
on peut le prouver
donc l'ensemble des ddd eca
réglementaire qui nous on gérait côté
notifié nous on a répondu donc le cours
des choses c'est que en plus les
enquêtes judiciaires donc ça va être
portée donc le le juge tranchera et dira
si mais pour nous on n'a pas géré
l'écart majeur qui ferait qu'on aurait
aggravé le sinistre
encore moins de cause et nous par
rapport à la demande qui vous avez été
fait d'enlever d'inventorier la totalité
des produits matériel stocké
j'en ai touche alors demandé tout alors
est-ce qu'il faut aussi enfin à vous
dire
à deux choses une chose que j'ai pas dit
mais je veux quand même rajouter c'est
que sur l'histoire des stocks savoir que
nous avions un établissement qui est
dans la zone rouge
en fait qui est à 50 mètres du bâtiment
courrier soit sur la vidéo on avait
notre siège administratif c'est dire que
pendant
depuis d'ailleurs la crise
nous ne sommes pas revenus sur notre
site sur le siège est en fait nous avons
nous avions tous nos documents
l'informatique enfin concernant la
circulation un peu de camping à
l'extérieur en fait de notre site et on
a du mal en fait beaucoup de mal au
début de la crise en fait déjà reprendre
nos esprits et puis à s'organiser pour
pour aller chercher les documents qu'il
fallait pour reconstituer certaines
choses refaire démarrèrent réinstaller
de l'informatique provisoire va tout un
tas de choses qui ont fait que
on était relativement à une situation un
peu précaire et donc nous a desservis
à vous écouter déjà on a compris mais
même avant de vous auditionné que la
partie n'est pas facile entre vous et
lubrizol puisque lorsqu'on est un
observateur extérieur on a quand même le
sentiment que chacun se renvoie la balle
et que bien évidemment ça ne peut pas
être satisfaisant pour les personnes qui
l ont subi directement les nuisances
vous avez précisé que vous êtes un
prestataire est donc si j'ai bien
compris
est-ce que cela vous oblige à la mise en
place de d'exercices de simulation de
situation de crise d'une part et si vous
y êtes contraint est ce que vous aviez
vous avez organisé ses entraînements à
des situations de crise
or vous dit que vous avez été dépassée
vous dit que vous n'étiez pas prêts est
ce que c'est parce que si ces
entraînements n'ont pas été mis en place
aussi vous peut-être regardera pas on
n'a pas d'obligation en fait par rapport
à notre gérer qu'une classement est
terminée voilà est juste dire que dans
le comité de transparence du 18 novembre
lubrizol dit avoir décidé de
stocker les produits finis chez un
prestataire spécialisé donc ça n'est
sans doute pas vous ce qui voudrait dire
que vous n'étiez pas un prestataire
spécialisé
alors est ce que ça existe mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
viens donc monsieur schmitt the doit
répondre maintenant alors je pense que
la situation en fait de lubrizol et la
note extrêmement différents on n'est pas
on a gardé conservé des relations que
j'aime reason l'on n'est pas enfin
quoique la presse ou puissiez penser on
a des intérêts différents avec lubrizol
dans le cadre de cette crise et ça ça
vous l'avez souligné je pense que c'est
tout à fait juste
et c'est vrai que inde est un des enjeux
majeurs en fait de la crise c'est de
connaître la cause de l'incendié
et nous on est très sereins par rapport
à ça lubrizol gérait évidemment
souhaiterait ça vienne de chez nous
parce que ça ne dégagerait totalement de
mai mais si vous voulez celle enquêtes
en cours elles exploitent et judiciaires
en cours qui qui qui donneront des
éléments nous on est très sereins
là-dessus après on peut raisonner
qu'avec ce qu'on connaît
ce qu'on a comme comme élément nous
disent voilà
concernant enfin réseau votre question
est ce que j'ai un peu oublié ce que
c'est moi c'est le plaisir de répondre à
ça on a effectivement pas d'obligation
du fait du classement
par contre
ce soc à vérifier mais je pense qu'à
partir du 1er janvier 2020
il ya des exigences supplémentaires
concernant la sécurité et la sûreté donc
ça c'est une chose alors sur le la
notion de spécialiser je crois pouvoir
dire que lubrizol a choisi des
prestataires qui sont classés seveso
seuil bas qui sont des prestataires
logistiques qui peuvent être classés
seveso seuil bas peuvent leur permettre
le cas échéant d'offrir à lui brise hall
des prestations que nous n'offrions pas
qui concerne le stockage de produits
toxiques
ou dangereux donc là c'est un choix
stratégique c'est une nouvelle
organisation logistique pour lubrizol
puisqu'ils ont effectivement indiqué
qu'il diminuerait le plus possible les
quantités stockées en tout état de cause
et en particulier les quantités stockées
sur leur propre site
donc ça c'est c'est effectivement public
ça a été dit mais on peut pas comparer
la qualification
spécialisée de confrères et l'offre de
services qu'ils vont donner à lubrizol
par rapport à un nouveau besoin de
lubrizol par rapport à ce qui était
l'utilisation par lubrizol de notre
proximité et lubrizol connaissait
parfaitement bien notre situation icpe
puisque dans le cadre de réflexion qui
était menée par lubrizol nous avions
fourni l'ensemble des documents
concernant notre classement icpe
et en sachant lubrizol savez ce qu'il ne
pouvait pas mettre chez nous non plus
donc c'est une différence de deux
politiques logistique que lubrizol fait
maintenant l'idée précédente
en se positionnant par acquérir le site
c'était d'être le propre faiseur sur la
totalité de sa gamme de produits et
parce que en fait ce à quoi vous faites
allusion en fait c'est surtout leur
propre site de stockage on est ce qu'on
appelle les bâtiments à 5 et à 4 mais
rien ne dit que les produits qu'ils
stockaient chez nous seront stockés chez
un spécialiste seveso ils n'ont pas
besoin
prenez c'est ça aussi quelqu'un qui
dirait que il faut comprendre c'est que
nous on stockait enfin dans ce qui a
brûlé il y avait principalement ce qu'on
appelle des vignes 43 c'était un
polymère inerte
oui ça et donc ses produits la fin
connaissant lubrizol est l'heure je peux
dire leur usage enfin en termes de ve
financier à mon avis ils peuvent éviter
de payer un stockage qui va leur coûter
beaucoup plus cher ils le font enfin
c'est parce qu'ils en ont pas la
nécessité absolue
le problème qu'on avait nous c'est que
cette fin cette proximité et puis 7
on va dire le lien dans le cadre du pprt
enfin l'a bien vu finalement que quelque
part le ce site soit une radio de
délaisser soit ils auraient dû l'acheter
c'est l histoire en fait du site et la
dréal on était parfaitement consciente
et j'irai même plus facilitateur c'est à
dire que c'était pour elle une façon
aussi de régler le problème est donc
finalement nous dans cette histoire bien
sûr nous on s'est retrouvé quelque part
dans une situation où bien certes on
aurait bien voulu s'en débarrasser de ce
site a tourné bien compris qu'il y avait
un souci mais mais on est aussi dans un
monde économique et on est bien obligé
de faire avec les éléments économiques
que l'on dispose des contraintes
justement cet égard est ce que les les
le projet qui avait lubrizol d'augmenter
sa capacité de stockage aurait conduit
selon vous alléger le stockage que vous
effectuez pour lubrizol j'en sais rien
je peux pas je en fait le problème c'est
que prévu une autorisation
vous le savez d'accorder deux alimentés
suis pas sûr qu'on parle d'elle même
sujet enfin jeu
le problème c'est que nous en fait
lubrizol on les connaît pas finalement
on les connaît si vous voulez que par un
client qui nous proposent des stocks et
des produits est consacré ça aurait pu
être pour un autre client dans la mesure
où ça répondait aux rubriques et aux
types de produits qu'on pouvait stocker
on aurait pu stocker des produits pour
clients tous les autres mais je dirais
que nous on s'intéresse pas beaucoup est
ce que font nos clients c'est leur
problème en languettes métier c'est déjà
assez dur comme ça apprend que parce que
la gestation est aussi compliquée face
et même si ça peut paraître
enfin vous avez je pense compris que
quand on voit l'ensemble des contraintes
pour des gens qui font notre métier de
logistique c'est extrêmement compliqué
et tout à l'heure vous poser la question
de savoir s'il fallait que l'on peut
être changer certaines choses
une des choses que je pense on essaiera
de faire façon plus pressé c'est
effectivement de faire des audits plus
fréquents en fait pour pour s'assurer en
fait que la réglementation qui change
très souvent et si on parlait de deux
nouveautés en 2020 mais ça change sans
arrêt donc pour se mettre à jour pour
des entreprises de taille va dire
relativement modestes comme la nôtre on
a besoin d'eux d'être et la dréal en
fait sont une partie de son travail
c'est un travail de conseil et de
d'amener en fait les entreprises comme
les nôtres
j'irai à faire évoluer dans
installations pour suivre et coller à la
réglementation donc évidemment post 6 je
pense qu'il faut pas sous la dréal c'est
une organisation g qui fait son travail
mais avec les moyens
pénible et le nombre d'installations aux
classes est quand même très importante
donc
quand vous disiez que vous n'étiez pas
préparés à ce genre de crise
si on pouvait remonter le temps vous
feriez quoi pour être préparés à ce
genre de crise outre autre que vous
venez de dire je pense que j'aurais été
beaucoup plus pressant avec le belge
aurait dit du brésil vous débarrasser de
tout ça mais en fait tu vois pas de
préparer parce que c'était pour nous
enfin la crise a été minime pas majeur
c'est dire que pendant on dire un mois
on a été totalement submergé par une
pression de toute part de
l'administration certes de des médias de
notre personnel de nos de nos banques
il faut savoir que celui pour nous c'est
au delà même en fait du sinistre qui est
quand même très important pour notre
entreprise c'est aussi en difficulté
parce que parce que l'ensemble enfin
l'environnement intéresse si tu m'aimes
sur notre métier on est impactée
indirectement même si commercialement
nos clients pour l'instant son sont
plutôt nous soutiennent et c'est donc on
n'a pas trop d'impact économique mais
c'est tout de l'impact indirect
sipa par rapport à ce que vous dites en
termes de segments je pense qu'on a une
particularité
je sais pas si elle existe beaucoup
ailleurs en france et non seulement on
est vous y faisait allusion déclaration
à l'assemblée nationale mais non
seulement on est à côté d'un seuil ces
réseaux enfin scellé au seuil haut
on n'est pas seulement à côté on est
mitoyen et quand on fait état de
l'antériorité et des quelques photos que
nous vous avons montré c'est que avant
il n'y avait rien autour de nous donc la
la la la curiosité c'est pas le fait que
nous soyons au milieu de deux sites
seveso
c'est que deux sites seveso sont venus
finalement ce run est devenu citoyen de
nous alors en termes de réflexion par
cette proximité
on sait qu'il y à des exercices qui sont
fait très régulièrement dans les sites
seveso par cette mitoyenneté par l'étude
de danger par l'étude des risques
on n'a jamais nous été intégré à
quelques exercices que ce soit par nos
voisins on était parfois précieux dire
on aura un exercice dont vous entendrez
des sirènes vous inquiétez pas c'est
normal mais il n'y a jamais eu
je ne sais pas si dans la relation
commerciale
il doit y avoir un rôle de conseil du
site le plus pointu en matière de
sécurité à l'égard du voisin qui est
juste à côté et de 10 rebonds s'il se
passe quelque chose on a nos équipes
tu as fait ce on va venir chez vous on
va vous apporter un coup de main
d'autant plus que se situe le
connaissait également parfaitement bien
pour y revenir quasiment quotidiennement
pour les problèmes simplement matériel
de stockage de manutention de produits à
sortir de pointage
également dans le cadre du pouls du
process de du process de cession pour
anticiper pour eux des travaux qu'ils
envisageaient de faire donc ça c'est
peut-être quand on est dans la on est
vraiment sûr de la mitoyenneté donc
c'est bon pas du voisinage ccit de la
mitoyenneté de s'interroger si on veut
dire ben saisit pas seulement peut-être
de mettre une salle de confinement tout
étant que l'accident ait lieu dans la
journée
et là pour le coup nous saluer la nuit
on n'a personne du tout notre entreprise
est complètement fermée on a rien à
l'extérieur et c'est peut-être dans des
logiques de deux zones d'activités ou de
zones industrielles
comment peut se faire je dirais la
communauté sécurité de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes
mais d'ailleurs on peut dire que
lubrizol a reconnu enfin c'est une
déclaration va donner dans une valise et
pas prévu en fait que enfin ils ont même
osé dire que c'est pas prévu que le feu
viennent de chez nous vraiment c'était
un petit peu là morin desailly une
question beaucoup atterri sur la
communication de l'événement
quand avez vous observé et comment avez
vous vécu cela et qu est ce que vous
auriez souhaité voir mieux communiquer
comment sûr sûr sûr sûr la communication
de l'événement
on a nous beaucoup souffert parce que on
a eu en permanence du retard sur la
situation
je le disais tout à l'heure du fait que
l' incendie n'était pas définitivement
éteint chez nous et donc ça c'était
notre première préoccupation que pendant
ce temps de préoccupation importante la
dréal faisait un contrôle approfondi
donc monopolisé aussi du temps le 30
septembre et le 7 octobre alors l'anc
est donc le temps paul enquête
judiciaire les perquisitions judiciaire
donc tout ce temps elle n'était pas
consacré à la communication sylvain
suite disait bon on est plutôt une
entreprise qui se veut d'être de au
service de ses clients et de qualité
on n'a pas voulu rentrer dans des
polémiques ça c'était un point de vue
peut-être que c'était une erreur quand
le dry à la déclarer qu' on avait des
écarts qui de son point de vue étaient
des infractions pénales nous considère
que c'est probablement plutôt un juge de
décider si un écart et est qualifiée de
pénal ou pas d'avoir très régulièrement
mis en cause
on pourrait presque dire la qualité de
notre entreprise grange se sait que
devant votre commission il a eu des
propos plus apaisés
bon alors on n'est pas rentrer dans la
polémique on a laissé la presse s'empare
et parce qu'on était quatre ou cinq
personnes en permanence
on pourrait dire 24 heures sur 24
agir et la fin d' incendies à gérer les
arrêtés préfectoraux qui nous imposait
un certain nombre de choses et c'est pas
le sujet que les impôts c'est le sujet
c'était de se mettre en oeuvre pour les
respecter donc et on a toujours cette
équipe qui qui qui est au travail et
d'intégrer continue voilà d'intégrer et
de comprendre des obligations qui nous
sont faites à niveau égal de celle de
lubrizol sur ce qu'on appelle le suivi
environnemental donc de faire des
prélèvements de terre d'air d'eau sur
l'ensemble des communes qui ont été
impactés par le panache de fumée jusque
dans les hauts de france
il a cité aux réunions le corollaire
c'est donc
donc on a on a on n'a pas eu le temps
par la communication et la question est
ce qu'il vaut mieux ne pas communiquer
être que mal communiqué je je je sais
pas aujourd'hui alors on a beaucoup subi
au début ensuite on a subi et agit
maintenant on asie plus qu'on subit donc
c'est aussi plus facile de peut-être
aussi passer maintenant pour nous dans
une phase plus communicante que qu'on
l'a fait jusqu'à présent bien m'écouter
même la porte à une dernière question
qui concerne le volontariat chez les
sapeurs pompiers je pense vous me
répondre mais il ya une proposition qui
consiste à favoriser le volontariat des
personnels des entreprises des sites
seveso
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
belle idée au phare on peut parler de
nos si on est passés les autres on
comparera pas de seleçao mais j'irai que
pour nous on a des salariés qui sont
pompiers volontaires on a on a
d'ailleurs on a un salarié qui est qui
et qui était qui étaient présents en
fait le jour de l'incendié qui a été
mobilisée qui est intervenu et qui a
donc c'est une bonne chose
encore faut-il que ces personnes là
soient présentes sur le site au moment
et j'irai que à vrai dire
heureusement qu'il est personne sur
notre site parce que toute façon ne voir
rien pu faire compte tenu de l'ampleur
en fait deux
et il fallait en fait je pense des
équipes spécialisées et qui qui est le
vol expérience et puis l'équipement pour
pour répondre fait l'incendié
et voilà vous en savez plus sur
l'incendié de l'usiné normandie
logistique voisine de lusine lubrizol à
rouen
selon les dirigeants de normandie
logistique l'état aurait dû les
expropriés de cet entrepôt entouré de
plusieurs usines à risques classée
seveso comme celle de lubrizol
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant c'est leur
dalon plus loin votre émission
d'actualité politique et parlementaire
présenté par rebecca fitoussi très bonne
soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]
oh